look at that it's empty
how am i going to get to work it's
stupidity
that we're all queuing up
but this is my job
is there petrol shortages no
it's mad isn't it
supply chain chaos soaring energy prices
and nhs buckling under a backlog the
threat of a covid19 resurgence
any one of these challenges would be
enough to cause serious concern but
they're all happening at once is it
going to last for months and could it
affect christmas i don't i think
everybody i think the supply chains are
very secure
but this is about far more than just
christmas it's about the risk of a much
wider winter crisis so what's going
wrong who could be impacted and how does
the government plan to avoid the worst
inflation has already been pushing up
living costs but as we head into the
winter those increases are likely to
continue
energy bills will rise significantly for
most people due to a huge spike in the
wholesale gas price and the cost of
everyday purchases from fuel to food to
furniture is being driven up by problems
caused in part by a shortage of drivers
post-brexit trade changes and global
supply chain pressures resulting from
the pandemic
the knock-on effect of all that is
uncertainty as the autumn rush for fuel
has demonstrated i've got
15 miles of petrol left i'm a community
physio
i need petrol to do my job i was on the
phone with my friend and he was driving
past the petrol station he was saying
about how kind of busy it was i know
what people are like because they tend
to panic don't they and then that causes
the shortage makes it all worse
while price increases and good shortages
will be felt by everyone those on low
incomes are going to be hit particularly
hard
the government has been heavily
criticized for pushing ahead with plans
to remove the 20 pounds weekly increase
to universal credit just at the time
these living cost pressures are kicking
in
the furlough scheme is also about to
come to an end
the government is hoping that employers
who have kept staff on furlough for this
long have done so because they intend to
take those staff back but if that
doesn't happen there could be hundreds
of thousands of people finding
themselves in a very difficult position
we're about to enter winter winter is
coming and people really should take
this seriously the government has been
clear that another winter lockdown would
only be considered as an absolute last
resort any responsible government
must prepare for all eventualities
given the rising living costs we've just
discussed they know that shutting down
the economy again would be catastrophic
particularly for those in the retail and
hospitality sectors who after last year
cannot afford to miss another crucial
christmas business period but there's
also an acceptance in westminster that
with the colder months people will mix
more indoors and that arise in cases is
inevitable the important thing to
remember is as we embark on the winter
months the virus haven't in inbuilt
advantage the big bet is that the
vaccine rollouts will mean the number of
people needing hospital treatment for
covid won't overwhelm the nhs but
there's no doubt that's a gamble
adding to that uncertainty is the
massive backlog that the nhs is
currently dealing with following the
pandemic and that could be compounded by
the seasonal pressures that normally
affect the health service an additional
five and a half billion pounds has been
given to the nhs in an effort to get to
grips with those ever-growing waiting
lists but ministers acknowledge things
could get worse before they get better
if there were serious disruption to
christmas as a result of a covid
resurgence or real chaos in the supply
chains there's no doubt that it would be
politically damaging for boris johnson
but even if that is avoided he'll be
aware people are likely to start feeling
the impact of these winter challenges in
their daily lives long before december
the 25th the government has weathered a
number of crises in the last two years
but that was largely thanks to an
acceptance amongst large swathes of the
electorate that the challenges posed by
the covent outbreak were unprecedented
the real political risk this winter is
that voters have lost patience and are
no longer willing to give ministers the
benefit of the doubt
when it comes to avoiding another
lockdown face covering rules vaccine
certificates for large venues and work
from home guidance could all be
reintroduced and on the issue of supply
shortages boris johnson says he's
confident the government can take steps
to ease the pressures a deal has been
done with suppliers in an effort to fix
the co2 shortage after fears were raised
by the food and drinks industry that it
could lead to empty supermarket shelves
and beer taps running dry
some support is also likely for energy
companies taking on the customers of
providers that have gone bust
and when it comes to wider supply chain
problems ministers have said they
believe market forces will ultimately be
the solution as businesses adapt
but even if that's right those changes
won't happen overnight so price rises in
the short term look unavoidable put all
of this together and you can see why
navigating the winter of 2021 could be
extremely challenging for the government
and for the millions of people being
impacted by a series of crises all
happening at
toilet
once
at uhd